- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
how to build self-discipline.
Over to you, Terry Crews.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- The thing about self-discipline is that
it is necessary for everything
you do in your life.
You have to be self-disciplined.
If discipline comes from somewhere else,
it's very very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist.
That's why because, I see trainers
and they're in the gym with people
and the guy or girl
that they're working out
hates their workout.
Hates it because the discipline
is coming from somewhere else.
It's something that you dread.
Every time you go in, you
don't really want to do it.
It's like, "Oh no, my trainer is here.
"He's about to beat me up
and make me feel crazy."
Well, the truth is every trainer
should work his way out of your life.
Anybody who's working you out,
your teachers, your trainers your people,
they have to train you
to get out of your life
so you can go ahead, do your own workout.
Do your own thing,
practice self-discipline.
- Successful people have self-discipline
but you have to make sure you're focusing
on the right things.
You can only force
yourself to do something
that you don't like for
so long until you quit.
So I think too many people
have the wrong goals.
Too many people don't
have the self-awareness
to know what they really should be doing
and have a strong enough why
to keep forcing them to do it.
A lot of people who become
entrepreneurs start a business
because they look at the
top 100 hottest companies
to start this year and that's
what they want to go and do
because they think it's
going to make a lot of money.
But if money is the only goal,
it's never going to work out.
Money yes it's important but
there has to be something
more important that you're striving for.
If you look at the top
people in any field,
they have deep passion for
their work that they're doing
and because they love it so much
it helps enforce the self-discipline.
So the best way that I've
found to stick to a schedule,
to make sure that I'm doing
the work that I want to do
is one, make sure that
I have a goal in mind
that I really feel passionate about.
But then two, create habits,
and a morning routine
and a schedule that support
me achieving that goal.
So whatever goal you have,
make sure that the work you're doing
maps to you creating that goal.
One of the hardest things that I find
is when I have a goal, and then I wake up
and my schedule's thrown off.
And this is going to
happen in life, right.
That's why I try to create
a no-crisis business.
But your schedule will at
some points be thrown off.
You've got to drive somebody to work,
or you've got to go to the hospital,
or some crisis happens.
I find it very hard to
get back on schedule.
Just like if you are
trying to stick to a diet
and you have that first chocolate bar.
Chances are the rest of your day
is going to get totally thrown off.
So if you wake up and
you set a morning routine
that sets you up for
achieving your success,
you're more likely to follow through.
As an example, if you want
to learn how to be fit,
you want to learn how to
take care of yourself,
you want to learn how to be motivated,
maybe waking up and watching
some Terry Crews every morning
is a thing that you should be doing
because maybe your
friends don't support you.
Maybe your family doesn't support you
but you've got Terry.
You watch him, he's motivating.
You want to go out and
do something bigger.
For me, that's why I
created the top 10 series.
That's why I created a lot
of the videos on my channel
because I wanted to be surrounded
with ultra-successful
people that I may never meet
and some people have passed on
so there's never a chance to meet them.
But I feel like I'm hanging around them.
And by watching their
videos in the morning,
not at five o'clock in the
evening and hoping to get
motivated for the rest of the night,
in the morning, to start my day off
so that I want to go off
and do something bigger.
So whatever that feeling
is, you have your goal
and whatever helps you get
motivated and get that feeling
that you can create on a consistent basis,
watching a video, talking to somebody,
reading a book, listening to a podcast,
whatever it is, start your day with that
so you have the right
environment around you
to help you maintain
the discipline to go out
and achieve your goals.
So the question today is, I'm
curious what is the one thing
that you're doing that really
helped you stay disciplined
to achieving your goals?
Leave it down the comments below,
really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Aji from elyonconsultants.com.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book, "Your One Word."
Really really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter typing)
- So Tony, one of the critics
actually that I once met said,
"Yeah, Tony's techniques, they were great
"for about a year and a half,
and then they wore off."
(Tony laughs)
What do you say to that?
- They're all simple,
if you don't work out,
you don't get a muscle, right?
So I always tell people,
this is a daily practice, like priming.
If you don't do that.
If you get up and you just
have no discipline whatsoever,
you get no value of anything.
Diets don't work when you don't do them.
Exercise doesn't work
when you don't do them.
But most of people already
have some experiences
that they want to shift, and
once you shift those things
your whole life changes.
But life is constant growth.
My life isn't here because I
went to one seminar one time
and now my life is fit for life.
I work out, I train my
mind, I train my body.
It becomes a lifestyle.
It's not just like you're
depending upon somebody else.
I'm not here to become somebody's guru.
I'm not here to give them a gift.
I'm here to open up their own gifts
and that's really what my work has been.
- I've never met a person
who is not successful
that didn't have a great amount
of self-discipline within their life.
Self-discipline and being able to perform
and being able to keep
your life on schedule
commitments and promises
and meet deadlines is
essential to success.
None of us can afford to have a life
that is controlled by someone else
or a life that is basically
controlled by our emotions.
I learned many years ago that
there are two kinds of people.
There's the type of person who says,
"I'm going to wait until I
feel like it before I do it."
And then there's a person who says,
"I've got to do it so
that I feel like it."
One will never get anything done
because they're still waiting
to feel the moment to move
and the other person
says, "No, I need to move
"and then I will begin
to feel the moment."
Sonya, self-discipline
is essential in your life
and in my life if we're
going to get things done.
So I have a challenge for
every one of you this weekend.
The challenge is simple.
As you go through your weekend,
and sometimes it's kind of,
hopefully an easier time of your week,
ask yourself, "Am I practicing
self-discipline in my life?"
Am I doing the things that I should do
because I need to do them or
am I kind of waiting to feel the moment.
Do like our friends
Nike say, "Just do it."
- When I was in high school,
I must have been maybe 16 or 17 years old.
And I went rock climbing
in El Dorado Canyon,
near where I grew up in Boulder.
I'd been climbing for
about three or four years
and I went to a climb called T2.
Now, at the time T2 was a
relatively difficult climb
and I went at it
with a kind of an arrogant
lack of preparation.
And I hadn't prepared for being able to do
certain kinds of finger cracks.
I figured, "I'll figure
it out when I get there."
and I also didn't pause,
and this I think is about
boldness and discipline.
I didn't pause to really double smack,
double check, all my systems.
Okay.
So I'm on the fourth pitch.
I'm about 400 feet above the ground.
I'm going across this
slanting crack system
that I'd started to have trouble with
and my forearm started to engorge
with blood and lactic acid,
which means at some point,
even if you're on a big hold,
your hands are going to melt off.
And I'm about to fall.
I'm 400 feet above the ground.
But it should be okay
because there's protection.
I'm tied into the rope.
I may take a fall but I'll get caught.
For some reason, and to this
day I still don't know why,
my brain triggered that
I should look at my knot
and I looked down at my knot.
My knot had come untied.
I had made the mistake of
never really thinking about
the best knots for certain
types of situations,
and I'd tied in with what's a bowline.
Now the advantage of a bowline
is that it's easy to untie, right?
The disadvantage of a bowline
is it's easy to untie.
It had come untied as
I kept moving across,
and it is just hanging in my harness.
I'm seconds away from
falling, only now I will die.
I will die if I fall off.
My forearms are melting,
and the knot had come untied,
and so I called out to my partner.
I said, "My knot had come untied."
What is he going to do?
He can't do anything.
He can just watch me fall to my death.
And there was an old
fixed piton in the rock
that was put there from the first descent,
an old soft-iron piton.
And I looked at it, and I
probably had 15, 20 seconds
before my hands would unwrap, if that.
Maybe 10.
I took a runner, and I
clipped it into the piton.
I clipped the piton into my,
that runner into my harness.
And just went, "Please, hold."
And I let go.
And it held.
I put in a backup.
I grabbed the knot, retied
it, went to the ledge.
I didn't convulse.
I was very calm at that moment.
I got the ledge, I went
into convulsive shaking.
I was sick to my stomach for days
because of whatever happened chemically.
What I learned from that is two things.
The first is that when you're
in an unforgiving world,
gravity is unforgiving.
It doesn't care.
It never takes a day off, ever.
And if you make one
mistake, it can kill you.
If it's the wrong kind of mistake.
What I learned is that sense of,
yeah I want to do adventurous things.
I want to climb rocks,
I want to be Yosemite,
I want to do things that
get my adrenaline going.
But I need the discipline
to always do all the right
preparation, to always
think about the right knots,
to always be crosschecking my system
so that I can do those
bold things and stay alive
in an unforgiving environment.
And as you and I spoke
about earlier today.
I think we're all heading into
an unforgiving environment
where we're going to have to
be both bold and disciplined.
The second thing I learned.
What if that piton had not been there?
We might not be here together.
It was just by chance
that that piton was right there.
I want to you realize
when you rewind the tape
of your own life, there
are these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way,
you might have gotten killed.
So what you have to do
is always be putting
those extra disciplines in place
because I was lucky to live.
And what I took from that is
I never want to have to
be lucky to live again.
I want to live because of my discipline,
not because of my luck.